this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the ad-free creator-controlled
streaming service when you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below
[Music]
what do thomas payne rosa parks albert
einstein helen keller john steinbeck
george orwell
pablo picasso nelson mandela bertrand
russell and martin luther king jr all
have in common
these historical figures among many
others are routinely taught about in
american schools
they're all praised for their various
contributions whether artistic societal
governmental or scientific
and they're all generally portrayed as
good virtuous and intelligent people
but they also have one more thing in
common something that's never mentioned
in american schools
they were all socialists in this episode
we're going to take a brief look at how
history
especially american history tends to
whitewash radical figures
and why it's done this video could
easily be an hour long
but since i have analytics that show me
just how long the average person watches
i'm going to try to keep this short with
that in mind we're only going to look at
a couple of the many historical figures
who have had their radical past defanged
by imperialist history
let's start way back in the earliest
days of the united states
these days it can be pretty hard to find
anything to like about modern
politicians in the u.s with many
americans complaining that in decades
past
those who ran for office possessed
integrity and unimpeachable morals that
current candidates lack
the further back most people look the
more wistful they seem to become
as i briefly discussed in my episode on
the electoral college americans tend to
treat the founding fathers especially as
these almost mythical figures who had
their best interest at heart and that
could do no wrong
in reality they were people just like
the rest of us and people
then and now aren't perfect some of you
may be aware and appalled that for
example
george washington and thomas jefferson
among others owned slaves
and believed in the superiority of the
european white man other americans might
not care about these flaws and just
brush off those beliefs as a sign of the
times
but not everyone who helped shape the
country had such disappointing values
values that are contemptible in the
modern era if you do a little digging
one of the founding fathers in
particular stood above the rest
dramatically ahead of his time
a champion of real equality as well as
american independence
thomas payne from the days of his youth
in england thomas payne had been
dedicated to improving the lives of
average people and the poor
he volunteered at his church to collect
money to distribute to the needy he was
once fired from his job as a tax
collector after advocating for better
pay
and striking over the matter after he
made his way to the american colonies in
payne found a position as editor of the
pennsylvania magazine where he advocated
for the abolition of slavery almost a
full century before the practice was
actually banned in the us
you may be thinking wait a minute could
thomas payne really have been a
socialist all the way back in the 1770s
that's a fair question as many people
consider the beginning of socialism as a
distinct ideology to be sometime around
the french revolution of 1789.
while he may not have had the
terminology we associate with socialism
today
payne checked all the boxes so we could
technically call him a proto-socialist
in that he followed a set of values that
had not necessarily been fully codified
payne was deeply concerned for the
world's poor he was staunchly against
the british rule of the american
colonies and he dedicated his life to
fostering a revolutionary spirit among
his readers
first in the colonies and then abroad
his most well-known pamphlet common
sense
decries rulers and those who lust for
power saying
men who look upon themselves born to
reign and others to obey
soon grow insolent selected from the
rest of mankind their minds are early
poisoned by importance
and the world they act in differs so
materially from the world at large that
they have but little opportunity of
knowing its true interests
and when they succeed to the government
are frequently the most ignorant and
unfit of any throughout the dominions
once the revolutionary war was over and
the founding fathers had settled into
positions of power
payne was expelled from government and
labelled unpatriotic for rightly
accusing a fellow diplomat of war
profiteering
not content with having freed just one
nation from hereditary rule
payne was determined to do the same
thing in france during their own
revolution
from his home in london and against the
will of both the british and french
governments
payne published the rights of man which
demanded the universal acknowledgement
of inalienable rights to the entire
population
and proposed systems to allow for these
rights to flourish those systems
included universal welfare
child care education and pension years
later having burned all his bridges with
the leadership of britain
france and the u.s payne died penniless
and alone in new york
only six people attended his funeral
today a plaque commemorates the site in
new york reading in part
the world is my country all mankind are
my brethren
to do good is my religion thomas payne
was not only more progressive than those
of his time
he was more progressive than even many
americans today payne opposed the
concept of private ownership of land and
admired the iroquois nation for living
sustainably and democratically he
supported universal suffrage
the right of workers to control the
capital they used and was the first
notable american to propose the
implementation of ubi
taken together all of this essentially
makes him the original american
socialist and people like bernie sanders
follow in his century's old footsteps
compare this information with what you
learned about pain in school
you probably knew he wrote common sense
which supported the colonial struggle
against the british crown
odds are that's all you were taught but
let's fast forward
to a more recent radical figure martin
luther king jr was and remains to this
day
the most well-known figure of the civil
rights era from 1955 until his
assassination in 1968
mlk fought for desegregation labor
rights the right for black americans to
vote
and countless other societal reforms
that today we take for granted
just about every american is familiar
with at least some of king's story
we are taught that he was a good
christian man who advocated for equal
rights and that he led a march on
washington and gave the i have a dream
speech
this of course ended racism and everyone
lived happily ever after the end
obviously that's not the case but that's
about the extent of the american
education on the civil rights era
here's the thing dr king was a far more
radical organizer than most
people today are aware american history
books tend not to include king's later
activism
he was staunchly anti-imperialist
harshly criticizing america's meddling
in foreign affairs
especially in vietnam he was opposed to
militarism and war
he rightly pointed out that poverty
could be eliminated with the tools at
our disposal
it was simply a matter of putting human
life over corporate profits
when he led the montgomery bus boycott
at just 26 years old king was already
devoted to the struggle for equal rights
but like anyone his opinions evolved
over time
as he led marches and spoke with people
from all walks of life he began to
realize that the problems black people
faced in america were a symptom of a
larger disease
between 1957 and 1968 king traveled over
6 million miles
delivered more than 2 500 speeches and
was arrested and thrown in jail at least
20 times
over that period dr king developed an
understanding of the way poverty
racism militarism and imperialism were
all tangled up together in the mess we
know as capitalism
he said call it democracy or call it
democratic socialism
but there must be a better distribution
of wealth within this country for all
god's children
martin luther king wasn't shy about
making his political beliefs known
it's just that modern histories like to
leave that part out to make king more
palatable
to make him seem like a harmless
do-gooder who just wanted black people
to be able to vote and drink from the
same water fountains as white people
that's not who dr king was he preached a
message of love and equality
but he was outspoken about the problems
plaguing america
he called the us the greatest purveyor
of violence in the world today
a claim which has only become more and
more obviously true over the decades
he condemned the nation's military
action against vietnam saying
the bombs in vietnam explode at home
they destroy the hopes and possibilities
for a decent america
this was absolutely true the money we
spent on that pointless destructive war
could have been far better spent at home
improving the lives of everyday
americans of all races because as king
noted
negroes are not the only poor in the
nation there are nearly twice as many
white poor as negro
and therefore the struggle against
poverty is not involved solely with
color or racial discrimination
but with elementary economic justice dr
king would continue to speak on behalf
of the poor downtrodden and forgotten
and not just those in america but around
the world until the end of his life
in 1968 the year of his death king said
in an interview
for years i labored with the idea of
reforming the existing institutions of
society
a little change here a little change
there now i feel quite differently
i think you've got to have a
reconstruction of the entire society
a revolution of values he knew that
milktoast reforms and compromise would
never be sufficient to save the country
and that radical change was needed
because of this while traveling to
support striking sanitation workers in
memphis tennessee
dr king was murdered at the time of his
death he had just a 30 percent approval
rating among americans
this is in stark contrast with the rosy
picture of an american hero were shown
in school
we're taught that most americans
respected mlk and that he changed their
minds
clearly our education system is a little
lacking in the accuracy department
today about 94 percent of americans say
they have a positive opinion of dr king
has something in the hearts and minds of
the american people changed over the
years
i don't think so i believe that the way
our history is presented is
intentionally misleading
it defangs our most radical figures and
presents them as whitewashed icons of a
generally accepted movement
women's suffrage civil rights labor laws
any time there has been a major popular
uprising in this country
our history books have picked a face to
be a convenient representative
a sort of moral arbiter we can project
our good feelings onto
while allowing the general population to
ignore the actual mass movements that
supported and carried these noble
figures
it's an intentional attempt to make
people believe that a single person with
a nice idea is all it takes to bring
about real and lasting change
the ironic thing is each of the people
portrayed in this way
recognized and publicly acknowledged
that a single person has no real power
and that a mass movement is necessary in
order to force positive change
those in power will never give up that
power without a fight
we need to realize that when we're
presented with an accounting of history
that does not engage with all the facts
we're being subtly conditioned to
constrain the scope of our worldview and
our politics
rosa parks was a brave woman who sat
where she wanted to sit martin luther
king was a preacher who wanted equal
rights
albert einstein was just a really smart
scientist picasso was just an artist
orwell and steinbeck were just authors
all of these people and many more have
been stripped of their radical beliefs
to make them acceptable for an american
capitalist audience
why engage with the actual convictions
these people held when we can just
rewrite their lives to make them
harmless figureheads that stand for
something entirely different today than
what they stood for in life
the people who use martin luther king as
an example of a quote good black
protester
are choosing to engage with a version of
history that does not exist
a version that has been molded to make
white people not feel bad about the
civil rights era
those people need to reckon with the
fact that they would have been in the 60
that held an unfavorable opinion of dr
king in 1968
why because if he were alive today his
convictions would put him on the front
lines of every divisive issue that so
many of these americans take as an
attack on their traditional values and
the greatness of our nation
anti-war anti-imperialism
anti-capitalism
and a radical love for the people our
predatory system has cast aside
that's why our history is whitewashed
radical figures so the mass movements
they represented won't inspire the next
generation
so we'll feel like we could never
measure up to these seemingly lone
actors who affected all that change all
by themselves
they weren't by themselves they had a
whole lot of normal people standing with
them in solidarity
and those people don't get a page in the
history books
if you'd like to learn more about any of
the figures i mentioned in this video
i've left some links in the description
for dr king in particular i highly
recommend you check out martin luther
king jr on curiositystream
it's a great short watch about dr king's
contributions to the civil rights
movement
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record of caring about great educational
content and the financial security of
those who produce it
they've got thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my creator friends
and i teamed up to build nebula so we
don't have to worry about demonetization
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiosity stream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below you'll also get access to nebula
100 free
for a limited time you can take
advantage of curiosity streams holiday
pricing and get 41
off their annual plan that's less than
12 bucks a year for both curiosity
stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiositystream or
check out nebula's exclusive content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism you can also watch
all my videos as they were intended
ad free there really is something for
everyone and by signing up at the link
below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes if you hated it go ahead and
drop a thumbs down
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you